it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we explore the cultural stories
of the day and for that we turn to
author of the upcoming book The
Unexpected light of Thomas Alva Edison
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Ray last week Publishers were
editing Roald all and this week Ian
Fleming what's happening
well the Fleming estate has announced
that they mean to cut James Bond in a
way even Goldfinger couldn't Laura the
Fleming estate and family is
re-releasing all the James Bond novels
editing out some of the most offensive
Parts the problem is the character of
James Bond in print and on the big
screen was known for what not his
sensitivity
is this the stupid mother that tells you
Uptown there seems to be some mistake my
name is Ames is for tombstones baby
y'all take this honky out and waste him
now think meet Felix lighter hello Felix
say hello to dink hi dank ding say
goodbye to Felix
man talk
in my curiosity but what is that
it's my little Octopussy
well the the Fleming estate Laura claims
that Ian Fleming who created James Bond
agreed to racially sensitive edits To
Live and Let Die in 1955 and they've
edited the rest of the books in that
Spirit I'm not so sure
I mean people have just gotta I'm just
it is what it was and just leave it the
way it was and if you don't want to
watch it don't watch it they say that
about pornography right if you don't
want to watch it don't watch it well I
know but we're not talking about porn
we're talking about novels and my
problem is if they want the brand and
the franchise but they want to shave
away what made the brand and the
franchise important which was what his
audacity and his non-political correct
appetites I mean in Fleming's last book
by the way was named Octopussy what are
they going to name it now OCTA feline
octopus I mean come on the line is not
drawn anywhere and it disturbs me as an
author where they might take someone
else's work and the New York Times by
the way the other in other media outfits
Laura are straining to make treasury
secretary Janet Yellen and historic
figure for the first time ever U.S
currency will bear the signatures of two
women treasury secretary Janet Yellen
and U.S Treasurer Lynn malerba both were
at the Fort Worth Bureau of Engraving
and printing to do the honors Jana is
the country's first female treasury
secretary malerba is the first Native
American to have her signature on U.S
currency oh my Lord note how they have
to say Yellen is the first female
treasury secretary to sign our currency
why not the first female treasury
secretary with a white Buster Brown
haircut I mean the fact is she's hardly
the first woman to sign American cash
that honor went to Georgia niece Clark
in the early 1950s and then in 1981 Bay
Buchanan the sister of Pat was Reagan's
Treasurer who also signed U.S currency I
think yellen's a little late to the fair
um yeah well if she you know if she was
going to Ukraine as well I understand
Raymond
yes you made a surprise trip there to
hand off the first of a 10 billion
dollar Aid package to the Ukrainian
president maybe she was having him also
sign some U.S bills Laura since he now
owns so many of them that's what I was
thinking well I'm thinking of the poor
ukrainians haven't they been through
enough I mean if if she does for Ukraine
what she's done for inflation here in
the United States they better Run for
Cover
Yellen could have saved herself this
trip to Ukraine Laura had she had this
new Chinese remote kissing advice that
I've come across that's right long
distance kissing is now a reality look
at this thing
leave it to the Chinese to take it one
step further met with silicone the
Chinese version looks exactly like a
pair of soft lips the gadget comes with
an app called kernel one meaning
possible kits not only can you send the
kids to your long distance lover you can
also upload it to the kissing Plaza so
that strangers can experience your kiss
can you imagine this Yellen could have
sent that device to Ukraine Laura and
kiss zielinski's took us without ever
having to leave home it would have saved
her a lot of frequent flyer miles but
this may be the most evil thing the
Chinese have created since Tick Tock and
covet I have to say I mean this remote
kissing advice just we need remote
intimacy Anonymous remote intimacy I
thought the Chinese were trying to have
more babies over there weren't they
how's this going to help in that regard
this is the one child
when 60 percent of our men are single
and there's a 30 we're at a 30-year low
in sexual activity uh this is the last
thing we need in America reality is
better than the virtual Variety Raymond
think about it they want a soy boy to be
James Bond and they don't they don't
want real kisses the word we're in
trouble
big Trump finally Biden held an event
tonight a black history event at the
White House where he's being criticized
now for disparaging his own race listen
to this and by the way you know I'm not
I I may be a white boy but I'm not
stupid
I know where the party I'm not joking
so the supposition is white people are
stupid
I mean this is really typical you know
uh geralist Joe Biden obviously he's
trying to Pander to Black voters who are
assembled here for black history month
but you don't do that by running over a
whole different race I don't know how
that advances racial uh Unity or not
believe that anybody he that doth
protest too much about not being stupid
Raymond great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else